for more information on tutoring
personalized video solutions or how to
support move university in the
production of more videos please visit
moof university com thank you and enjoy
here's a question that might be asked
which metals are attracted to magnets or
magnetic fields generally speaking in
the macroscopic world we only think
about metals that are strongly attracted
to a magnetic field so those are our
iron Fe cobalt CO and nickel and I now
on a microscopic scale or our smaller
scale at least here we'll consider two
definitions paramagnetic and diamagnetic
something that's paramagnetic or that
exhibits paramagnet magnetism is
attracted to a magnetic field okay we're
at minutes diamagnetic or exhibits
diamagnetism is not attracted to a
magnetic field so this this series is
about electron configuration so it must
relate to this right and yeah it does so
when it comes to something that's
paramagnetic something that's
paramagnetic contains at least one
unpaired electron whereas no that's
diamagnetic contains no unpaired
electrons so let's consider two examples
iron and zinc so iron its electron
configuration everything up to argon and
then 4s 2 3 d 6 so 4s 2 1 2 3 d 6 1 2 3
4 5 6 ok so does it have unpaired
electrons yeah of course there's one
there's one there's one there's one
these guys are paired but the point is
it has at least one unpaired electron
therefore this is paramagnetic and it's
attracted to a non magnetic field that
makes sense iron we already know is
strongly attracted to a magnetic field
about zinc so zinc's configuration up
through AR and 4s2 3d10 so for s2 will
be filled 3d one two three
or five six seven eight nine ten are
there any unpaired electrons nope so
this is diamagnetic and not attracted to
a magnetic field okay that's basically
it I hope you can keep this in mind if
you're ever at asked about the magnetic
properties of a metal hope that video is
helpful thank you for watching if you
found that video helpful don't forget to
Like comment subscribe and share with
friends thank you and happy studying